you were Aztec half house tech right
yeah my father's side my heritage is
from Mexico City yeah what now tell us
about the Aztecs cuz I must admit my
knowledge of South American history is
not as good as it should be um yeah I
mean well we were colonized a long time
ago so a lot of what we should know
about ourselves is lost but I carry on
the tradition passed on by my
grandfather my ancestors passed on to my
father and given to me by my name and
through the traditions that they see
like we always hear their warriors there
yeah it seemed very badass I always say
so no for sure I definitely consider
myself a warrior so and a warrior and
you ever and you're a warrior for a
great cause which is the environment I
mean you're here because you've made a
lot of news first of all you've made
three speeches right at the UN that's
correct
Wow that's three more than I've made uh
and they were all on the environment
environment climate change my generation
all right yeah yeah you're 16 mm-hmm you
may be the youngest person on our show
set in record that's what's up
so
you have this lawsuit tell us about the
lawsuit so myself and 20 other youth
plaintiffs are coming together and
working with an organization to actually
work with our judicial system to say
that they have the the government has a
right that we have a right to a healthy
atmosphere and they are directly in
violation of our public trust and of our
constitutional rights well you think
they're not doing enough to help you
breathe yeah exactly you think breathing
is part of your rights
I say it's pretty important I know right
I mean it's not specifically in the
Constitution but life liberty and the
pursuit of profit how could you have any
of those if that you don't have
breathing room climate change is the
defining issue of our time is that
defining I always it can I always say
sobbing I always say the same thing they
say there's every other issue and then
there's that issue because if you don't
solve that issue there are no other
issues and as an indigenous person that
was always part of their culture right
was to to take care of the earth well
yeah I mean if you look at before Europe
came and kind of messed [ __ ] up over
here you know we were doing all right
living in balance with the world and so
I guess taking those principles and
taking those understandings that were
passed on to me and working with
technology innovation and what this you
know new generation like my generation
is more innovative and have more
entrepreneurs and ever before so we can
really work together to build a new
world by calling out our leaders and
we're finding them but not doing the job
that they're to do
and let's not let's not pretend you are
typical of your generation how many of
your generation would give up their
iPhone um yeah I'm not gonna answer that
no I mean no I mean you know it's not
just teenagers I mean the people in
their 20s don't don't vote as much as
they should I mean it's it's a part of
you that mean you have too many hormones
it's no you too many hormones and you
can get [ __ ] up too easily without it
hurting you yeah those I I know from
wherever I speak yeah yeah well I think
well I mean part of that too is that
like we're young and technology has
pulled our attention away from the world
in a lot of ways because right our
generation is being bombarded with media
that's showing us that it's over you
know climate change is the greatest
issue of our time we have politicians
that aren't supporting you know our
survival and there's so many problems
all over the world everywhere we look
there's more crises and there's no way
for our voices to be used to create
solutions so young people are searching
for that there's no outlet for us to
engage in a world that is stacked
against us we're distance systemically
disempowered from the time that we're
born so this generation what I've seen
personally traveling around the world
and talking to more and more of my
generation is that you know young people
are ready to use their art their poetry
their passion their music to engage with
the world and be leaders today because
you know sure we're a future generation
but we're here now and we're not going
to wait to make a difference which is
our wall